he is part of MLB network's coverage on
MLB tonight at 6:00 p.m. Eastern Time
man is there and is there a network that
Ron darling is not a part of his he's
back here on the Rich Eisen show how are
you Ron I'm doing great thanks so what
are you what I guess let's start macro
what did you make of that world series I
mean a lot of folks are talking about it
having top to the year before what's
your take on it I think I think it did
and it's hard for me to say after seeing
a team when its first championship in
108 years but the back-and-forth the
games that were close and not so close
the slugging and the pitching the the
bullpen usage where they have 56
pitching changes in that series you know
I find that the most ironic part of it
is that here are the Dodgers who had the
best bullpen that I ever saw against the
Cubs
and in the postseason until they faced
the Astros and really the Astros had the
untested bullpen but they kind of
figured it out or AJ Hinch figured it
out by the end of Game seven that he
just used his starting pitching to get
through the game so yet McCullar is a
starting pitcher peacock a starting
pitcher and Morton finished up with four
innings instead of using the bullpen so
that was pretty ingenious of our AJ so I
guess what you need to get through that
Dodger rotation and into the Dodger
bullpen and make it look far more
pedestrian than it was was to have a
bunch of 20 year olds who I guess don't
really know what they shouldn't know and
just hit out of their shoes and just
mash it up which is basically what these
young astro hitters did from basically
it one through four in the lineup that's
for darn sure
they were terrific hitting the baseball
Ron I just just like you did I'm sure I
just marvel at the talent at such a
young age that these young players have
I think you know when I played a
thousand years ago you know I we would
play the best players in our city or
town or Hamlet or whatever these young
players now are playing on travel teams
against the best people in the world and
by the time they get
20 to 23 years old they're well abled to
play in these kind of games and I think
you're right they just you know they
played with a carefree sometimes care
less time type of attitude and when the
pressure is on
boy that that seems to go a long way and
you know the thing about the Astros that
I really enjoy is that no we hear about
the analytics but you know they also
went back in time to do some things that
that teams have always done and that is
acquire the great gun at the end and
Verlander they acquired guys like
Beltran McCann and Radek guys that would
help in the clubhouse with a lot of a
young players so you know it was the
combination of the analytics the
acquisition of veterans and of course of
that young core that might be around for
a while yeah and and let's talk about
the MVP of the World Series after Game
one where the Dodgers won and mopped him
up in less than two and a half hours who
would have thought that the guy with the
golden sombrero in that game would be
the MVP eventually of this World Series
with the first ever performance within a
single word series of home ring in four
straight games this kid George Springer
everything about him I love everything
about him I love his game I just love
his attitude his story overcoming
stuttering as he explained to to
everybody when he wore a microphone
during the all-star game for that
express purpose to teach kids with
stutters that it's nothing to be afraid
about I love that kid I'm wondering what
your thoughts on George Springer are Ron
yeah I'm the same as you know I'm an
East Coast kid so seeing a kid from
UConn do as well as he's done I I think
the the whole thing that he does because
of his stammer and stutter as a child
and overcoming that and showing young
people out there that are probably uh
wallflowers and don't want to be out in
front because of their issue I think he
sent more good that way than a yes even
with the four home runs in four straight
games and then you know his ability to
get over a game
I saw Willie Wilson and you did too in
the World Series in 1980 never recovered
from striking out in the first game of
the World Series and he had a tough goal
of it so we've seen great players not
able to come back and and I think
today's athlete at least in baseball the
guys I see they really do a great job of
just forgetting about yesterday and
moving on Bellinger did the same thing
on the other side after he had had a
rough night so these kids are fun to
watch baseball's in a really really good
place especially if you like strike up
an almost there's no gray area is there
there's zero gray zero Ron darling of
MLB network's MLB tonight can be seen
today at 6:00 Eastern and three Pacific
here on the Rich Eisen show and what I
thought about just looking back at this
playoffs and World Series for the Astros
okay is that the these kids in that on
that team kind of have a g-wiz moment
for them like I can't believe we've gone
from a hundred losses to winning it all
I think the fact that they're now gonna
be world champs with that swagger okay
young guys with that swagger makes them
particularly dangerous over the next
five years Ron that this team how many
do you think they can win over the next
five years well I think they have a core
like the this the last team to repeat 98
99 and 2000 of course the core of that
Yankee team they have that kind of a
core group now that being said you're
right they have a swagger but they also
there's something very humble about
their swagger you know what I'm saying
like when you hear them and they walk
the walk and he and and they'll bat flip
you and the whole thing but at the same
time to listen to an out today and it's
one of the best players on the planet
that's what's great about baseball five
six you can do that the way he speaks
about his teammates whenever he's in the
spotlight he deflects it all to the
other players their ability after you
know of Dallas Keuchel
knocked out to group up together as a
young infield and say hey if we're going
to go down let's have fun you know let's
just have fun going down I mean those
that's very very adult kind of things
that the young players did right there
so how many can it was I think they're
gonna be in it for you know the next
four or five years I think you and I
both know that this winning eleven games
is is it's really tough but secondly
it's you know it can you sustain it for
an entire month that's hard and it's a
team that's playing the best and I I
thought the Dodgers after that cup
series we're going to be unbeatable and
that's how good the Astros are and what
do you think this means for Carlos
Beltran what goes through the head of
this this guy who's done everything
except to put a championship ring on his
finger which now he gets to do you know
we saw the emotion last night from from
Carlos who might be one of my favorite
players that I've ever covered
and watched the grace and humility that
he plays with I think he's a Hall of
Fame player I think that if you know and
I don't know well enough to know this I
would pack it up take it home he's such
a humanitarian Puerto Rico needs him
they need a person like him to be on the
front lines of helping that country
recover I think that's where I'd love to
see him because he's been a great player
he could still play I'm sure and help
help a team but I think it's time to go
out a champion because that's what he's
always been and then on the other side
what do you think the Dodgers do next
what do you think their next moves are
huh that's interesting yeah I think you
know you look at two teams the Astros
when I've got Verlander the Dodgers went
out got Darvish um you know Verlander
was the better of those pickups
obviously I I think you know their
bullpen is as strong as it's ever been
so maintaining that the core of their
young players is going to be interesting
because what do you do with Adrian
Gonzalez if he's healthy next year
where's Bellinger play because he proves
he should be in there every single day
obviously
you know I think that you know the world
series for me kind of changed and the
two two ways for the Dodgers and and
this is not to criticize because it's
easier for me to sit in my apartment and
watch the game and and think about it
but the bullpen was really spent for the
Dodgers and there were two moments that
they could have rebooted it the hills
you know hills first start certainly
could have been a longer start which
would allowed a less work for the
bullpen and and I think you know the the
lefty would start both of those starts
if if Dave wasn't as eager to show off
his shiny new Cadillac which is that
beautiful bullpen that was great in
against the Cubs they might have been a
little more respite what happens in
World Series is that the more you see of
any pitcher the better chance you're
going to have against them and that
shiny new Cadillac shine came off during
the World Series last one for you Ron
let's give folks out there watching and
listening a little bit of hope for their
team because that's another reason why I
think watching the Astros was inspiring
to a lot of fans and brought a lot of
folks under the ratings tent in this
world series is that you can go from a
hundred losses to winning it all just
like that over a few years we did see
what the Indians looked like and what
the Yankees looked like young teams with
a young core we also see that in the
National League but give me a team right
now that is building on the
down-and-outs that you think can be the
next Astros three years from now Ron
boy that's that's interesting classic
Milwaukee Brewers are a team that has a
tremendous amount of athletes they
stayed in the race for most of the
summer this year in fact led it by five
and a half at the break I like what I
see in Arcia and Santana and and others
I think they had a lot of young talent I
think that's a team that could that
could be there
and and I just think that you know two
years ago in 2015 were raving about the
New York Mets starting pitching and what
we found out two years later how quick
the game can change is that if you don't
have what really translates in this game
is young everyday players two reasons
one is because they play every day
that's obvious but two they get hurt
less and and and that is the real
currency I think in today's game whoever
had the good young players is going to
be a team that's going to to be in the
mix the next four or five years we're on
another great baseball season out of you
really love love it love listening to
your call you make me smarter for
listening to what you say on the air
it's just terrific to hear and now that
the season's over though I don't want to
go all the way to March without talking
to you okay okay well whenever whenever
you call me and we'll level chat maybe
looks at about the NBA are you into the
the Association I'm more of a hockey guy
you know I'm from Boston so I'm more of
a hockey guy but you guys don't spend
too much time on hockey but me I I can
figure it out just let me know what I
have to talk about I figured well look
here's what we'll do is we'll talk some
pops we'll talk some Association Evan
Gattis does have like a playoff beard
when it comes to hockey I mean the the
beards are all over the place basically
so we'll chat very soon that's the
Millennial thing I can't grow up here
cos it's just great ooh and I both
you're preaching to the choir great chat
with you Ron it's Ron darling MLB
tonight for more Rich Eisen show tuned
to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the
doesn't show up